[Music]
Picador all right then no that's my dork
pick another door was roaming here you
know what you were right this is your
door
what's the matter you got a lot of bad
guys behind that door
access granted access denied access
denied access denied through cobs and
Turkish or we've got unfinished business
sure sister took something from me a
virus could wipe out half the population
and I want it back
gonna tell me just what we're dealing
with here it's my family when it's the
fate of the world it becomes my business
his whole thing sounds really dodgy took
off your sister listen the only way we
survive this working together like a
team let's do this
buckle up that way you have no idea how
long I've been waiting to do that
let's see if we can get it sick so you
guys are being hunted by an army of
mercenaries led by a genetically
enhanced soldier look at me crazy
yeah he really is black Superman you
need to get off the grid where oh my
babies come home I'm sorry to bring
trouble here mama but I need my brothers
this family is going to war we're gonna
need cars and guns mama where's all our
guns
okay read up on very noble mrs. Hobbs no
it's serious trouble yes understatement
let's get old-school
come on
we're going for a ride
somebody's not happy
indeed him of the future of the planet
under necessary shops of the system
I am human evolutionary change
bulletproof superhuman
who the hell are you bad guy the mission
has been compromised
we need help our targets name is Brixton
he's a ghost we're gonna need the best
trackers in the business Luke Hobbs on
what you call a nice cold can of
whoop-ass career low man always gets his
guy we're gonna need to operate outside
the system Deckard Shaw I'm what you
might call a champagne problem rogue
former mi6 agent doesn't play well with
others
if we stand a chance against Brixton you
guys have to work together
this job requires stealth look at you
I'm trying to save the world which for
the record would be my one time cuz I'm
really good at it you have no idea what
we're dealing with
Pop's ensure
war
you've gone
remember me
what
[Music]
three shocks will kill a man there we go
the bad guy speech
you had so I'm your big mouth yeah yeah
the moment
[Music]
you